want to save the planet don't have kids
more and more people are coming to that
conclusion the New York Times has
profiled the growing group of people who
say they were refusing to have children
because they don't want to contribute to
global warming
Joseph Palermo is a professor of history
at Sacramento State University he says
that's about the right idea and he joins
us tonight professor thanks coming up
hey thanks for having me Tucker I need
to make something clear though yes what
we start on from Sacramento I have to
give a shout out to Anthony Sadler our
student here at Sac State
who's playing himself in the new Clint
Eastwood movie he graduated 2017 from my
distant view to him great guy he is well
I'm impressed well there I will see
indoctrinating the students and telling
them to be worried about trigger
warnings and post-structuralism
well that kid is brave he'll say that at
Sac State well you're right yours is go
Hornets Amen Hornet all right see that
wasn't bad I usually hate that stuff but
that was a good one
okay so let me say it but the other
thing no I know but the other thing I
gotta get you promote anymore I can't no
no I can't do that
I'm sorry chest I might know red you
gotta stop or else I'm gonna get any no
I know so did Chris Matthews no well
that's not Chris Matthews book can't
even come up yeah well that's dumb okay
I'm crazy here's the question so you
think that people should have fewer kids
because of global warming but all the
highest birth rates are in Africa I mean
all of them basically go to the top 15
so it's Malawi and it's Somalia and
that's Burkina Faso
you're telling African women to have
fewer kids is that what you're saying
that is what you're saying well let me
yeah this is going to put a furrow in
your brow Tucker I'm telling you right
now because although I think that
article is legitimate in that it raises
some legitimate concerns it's really a
dumb article that we're talking about
because what are we gonna do stop
reproducing the species it's not going
to happen we're gonna have children I
don't believe that we should stop having
children I believe we should look to the
future and look at what the markets are
telling us right now which is that
renewables REME you know solar wind all
of those the capacity is increasing
they're saying
global capacity for renewables and
electricity globally by by 2020 2025 is
going to be increased by 40% there's
going to be yeah I mean that's there's a
joke but Solar is real but but but will
that Nolan there are a lot of people out
there well then there are a lot of
people out there who are arguing the you
shouldn't have children or you want to
limit the number of children you do have
because of the earth and that and the
pressure that they put on the earth and
I guess my question is are you going to
take this message to the countries that
are having the most children all of them
in sub-saharan Africa and - it's a
little anti-human isn't that message
look.we you know as I'm a historian oh
let's go back I mean I'm telling you
this country has already been through
that whole thing it's called eugenics
and the early 20th century
no I don't want to go there what we want
to do is we want to work all together
people in all the world to face a global
problem
I mean Fox Business News just on
December 20th was urging its readers to
think about investing in alternative
fuel stocks I mean Elon Musk is going to
have a hundred thousand electric semi
trucks in the next four years he wants
produced 100 thousand a year he just
shot a Tesla in outer space that's the
future we and the stocks are showing
that the markets are showing okay almost
so the stock market is over this is why
I love liberal stuff is like the stock
market's always right now is the stock
question you take a lot of your cues
from the stock market so if like tobacco
stocks go up is smoking okay no I'm just
saying that that back in the day you
know when when Henry Ford was moving the
country to automobiles there were people
saying oh we've got to hang on to the
whip and buggy industry and let's remove
that we moved in there are a lot of
people that were moving into electric
electric fuels electric vehicles I mean
just shot a car in the space well I know
it was so impressive if I'm not sure
what that means
freakin a factory we leave in the 19th
century were going into the 20th
selenium just get that let me just some
of the substance are almost out of time
and this interview is obviously totally
insane is there anything about the
future integrity
we're okay there you go this is a new
liberal position markers have spoken is
there anything about technology or
markets that makes you uncomfortable at
all are they always good and right
there's a woman running for governor in
Minnesota right now on economic stimulus
to tackle climate change I mean we're
moving for there's a conservative group
in Wisconsin it's all good
Wisconsin conservative energy forum
nothing could go wrong
conservatives technologies always all
right moving forward I love your shop
like faith professor and I'm not going
to do anything you know what I'm not
gonna tell you that Santa's not real
because I don't want to hurt you hey
thanks professor great to see you
tonight